[Music]
if he was doing this on his own Facebook
and his own YouTube account that would
be fine
but he's doing it on my Facebook account
and my YouTube account and it's not fine
he's already gotten three patrons and
it's been an hour but you know what like
I say I'm just going to keep going
bab-oh it's not the only one who knows
how to dance and he's certainly not the
same kind of teacher that I am so let's
dance you want to play Favell so it's
fab okay looks like he's got some rhythm
he's not a bad dancer he's just kind of
a pervert
and I like to think I've helped the
people dance with a boy so let's talk
about rhythm and dancing with less
pelvic thrusting you know nothing wrong
a little wiggling in fact I think the
point is to get a little Wiggly
so get your poi makes it a little bit
short if you want to get into the music
of poi you want to get really good at
changing the length of your poi so you
can adjust to the speed of the music so
the beats
we've got here if I make my pour a
little bit short down boom boom it's a
little fast but we can really work with
that it's nice to be a little fast
because then you can go fast fast fast
fast fast slow fast slow fast fast fast
fast slow fast slow fast fast fast fast
fast slow fast slow fast fast fast now
these are all down swings it's like I'm
imagining there's a drum below my hands
and I'm putting the beat on the bottom
of the circle and that's how people
usually start and they get stuck there
but it's still a good place to start and
what I'd say is right from the beginning
stop worrying about moves right
because if I do this it's just like a
shoulder real the hip real with extra
circles who cares I can enjoy that I can
go higher higher higher higher lower
lower lower lower no oops doing the left
to the right and then back to my hip
Rio's and show the reals
but the thing is it starts getting a
limiting what you will need to do if
you're just counting down circles if say
you're going through the pattern is that
the music's four four four it's all work
you have to something like this left
shoulders red left shoulders right left
shoulders right shoulders left shoulders
right left shoulders right left
shoulders right boom left shoulders red
left shoulders right left shoulders
right left shoulders right left shorts
here I mean because there's three down
circles in the pattern if it's the four
for music it keeps going to the next
spot on the one and music boom boom boom
right boom
boom left boom boom shoulders but you
can really work with that to cultivate a
dance
[Music]
boom-boom-boom-boom
but this is just getting started because
we want to go beyond just down beats
because I can also do up up down up down
up down I can start imagining this and
drum at the top as well I can drum the
ceiling down up down up down down up up
down up up up up up
[Music]
next step I can Majan a drum on that
wall that wall and that wall left wall
right wall left wall right wall up one
wall down the other up one will dance
that's nice because now it's just
perfect for for rhythm up one wall down
the other up one wall down the other
right do that 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 the
ones on that wall 3 in that wall ones on
that wall 3 now the 2 and the 4 1 2 3 4
1 2 are behind my back if we think that
they move that way I've got four drums 1
drums the wall to my right
another drums up behind my hips so it's
like the top of the circle behind my
hips
the next drum is going up the wall to my
left and the fourth drum is down behind
my shoulders so if I do that this basic
rhythm of a hip real disorder real
go down hips up shoulders down between
them
[Music]
I'm making all of this up on the fly
because that's the only way I'm gonna be
able to keep making videos is if I just
go for it okay so tell me whether any of
that makes sense and what do you want to
see more of that kind of thing because I
can keep going into that looking into
that and that could be a lot of fun
get some mojo going get some energy
going yeah to interact with me
tell me and we'll keep playing I'm gonna
keep trying to make a video every day
[Music]